the Great Depression sucked for a lot of
people when it's discussed it's often
only in reference to the United States
or Germany in the impact that it had on
their societies but what about the other
major powers in the world how much if at
all did the Great Depression affect them
and how did their leaders try to deal
with it so as you'll probably know the
Great Depression began in the late 1920s
this led to businesses collapsing people
losing their jobs those people then had
less money to spend meaning other
businesses couldn't sell stuff meaning
theirs went bust and so forth this led
to a downward spiral that saw
International Trade collapse so how did
it affect the great Powers polar
opposite to the United States was the
Union of Soviet Socialist republics one
of the two communist countries in the
world at this point and given that they
were under International sanction and
barred from most cross-border trade the
Great Depression had very little effect
on it in fact being able to point a
decline in capitalist economies was a
massive propaganda Boon especially when
combined with the hundred thousand U.S
citizens that went to the Soviet Union
for a better life just in time for the
coming purges the lack of opportunities
in the rest of the world saw many
technical experts head to the USSR to
help set up factories which meant that
as a result the USSR saw substantial
economic growth whilst the rest of the
world declined an effect which helped to
bolster support for communism across
numerous countries in Britain the Great
Depression was different to the United
States in that the British government
had cleverly prepared for it you see
it's impossible to enter an economic
depression if you never left one which
was the case for the UK which had been
in a prolonged economic downturn since
the end of the first World War the
British government panicked and sought
to balance its budget because it was
running out of gold reserves as such
prime minister Ramsay McDonald sought to
raise taxes and cut spending which is
party the labor party couldn't
countenance as such he quit the labor
party and then formed a new labor party
and governed with the conservatives
Britain would recover from the
depression by 1935 because the only way
was up at that point this was mostly due
to it leaving the gold standard and thus
being able to devalue the pound to boost
exports and unemployment went down
fairly quickly after Britain began a
program of Mastery Armament just in case
that new German government got up to
something France avoided the worst of
the crisis because it was much more
self-sufficient in things like like
Agriculture and Manufacturing there was
a mild effect on employment but France's
decline was mild compared to Italy's
Americas or Germany's it did however
take a long time for France to recover
from this decline relative to other
nations because it fiercely held on to
the gold standard many in France hated
the idea of devaluing the Frank and so
it wasn't until 1936 that they actually
came off the gold standard and devalued
their currency to boost exports Italy
was similar in that it also fiercely
stuck to the gold standard but the
government there also saw the Great
Depression as an opportunity when
important businesses collapsed the
government stepped in and given that it
ran a surplus it was able to use excess
money to continue paying wages and
producing Goods Italy's economy was the
second in Europe to recover after
Britain's and the crisis gave Italy's
government near complete control over
its economy which it would soon turn to
war outside of Europe Japan was the
first major economy to recover from the
Great Depression this was because its
government opted to immediately devalue
its currency and spend a bunch of it on
keeping businesses open this led to
Japan's economy growing quite rapidly
whilst the European powers were still
stagnant meaning that the Japanese
economy was much better prepared for
foreign Ventures the major Powers had
mostly recovered by the beginning of the
second world war but it wasn't until the
mid-1950s that all of them had beaten
their pre-depression metrics I hope you
enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to my patrons James bisonnet
Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle Corsa
wolf Jerry lambdin Jordan Longley Adam
Stalter Marcus Arsenal YN hockey Spencer
Lightfoot rod D Martin words about books
podcast kept inside augustaf Swan Marvin
cassau commune Winston K wood boogly
Wiggly Daniel to be in Miss izet Aaron
the white Corey Turner the mcwhopper
Alex Schwinn Anthony Beckett Coppertone
Maggie Paskowski she went in spinning
three plates and Charles the first